Je n'ai jamais fait de film que je regarde maintenant et je suis vraiment c'est vrai tourmenté à propos de j'aurais aimé ne pas l'avoir fait tu es Jeff Goldblum la star de cinéma en fait oui c'est vrai je suis Jeff Goldblum eh bien je
sympa content de te voir si euh tu sais je je te connais mais si tu l'étais si tu devais te présenter à quelqu'un ici en France quelqu'un dans un club ou quelque chose comme ça que ferais-tu euh que ferais-tu que dirais-tu quelqu'un qui ne
Je ne sais pas vous que diriez-vous euh je je dirais je suis je suis Jeff Goldblum des États-Unis je suis un acteur j'ai fait un tas de films peut-être que vous m'avez vu à la volée je pense que c'était le
le plus euh populaire ici et euh en fait je vais être dans un film qui sortira bientôt appelé euh Mr Frost avec euh Alan Bates et Kathy Baker eh bien c'était euh difficile de devenir une star à Hollywood ou avez-vous
comment est-ce arrivé était-ce difficile Je suis allé à New York après avoir grandi à Pittsburgh en Pennsylvanie et étudié dans un gr
j'ai mangé une école de théâtre mais très peu de temps après avoir obtenu mon diplôme presque un an, j'avais 18 19 ans. Je suis tombé dans un travail de théâtre et j'ai fait quelques pièces, puis Robert Altman m'a vu dans une pièce de théâtre à New York et m'a demandé de faire une Californie
je me suis séparé puis j'ai fait Nashville et une chose en a entraîné une autre, alors j'ai continué, j'ai continué à travailler et et en fait, je n'ai jamais eu à avoir un travail direct
vous vous sentez déjà comme ce personnage du tout je non je je ne me sens pas comme la la la mouche bien que ce personnage vous savez ce qui m'a plu à propos de ce personnage était qu'il était romantique et héroïque et euh j'avais une partie passionnée et poétique de
moi-même et euh et euh et et j'ai l'impression que parfois parlez-moi de Mr Frost à propos de votre nouveau film Mr Frost euh oh c'est un film très euh intéressant vous savez je c'est avec comme j'ai mentionné Kathy Baker et Alan Bates je suis un mystérieux et
dangereux et charmant séduisant et imprévisible et spontané
personnage aneous qui établit un contact très intime avec Kathy Baker et euh et d'une part la détruit mais d'autre part l'ouvre et de belles histoires d'amour violentes et dangereuses quels sont les que diriez-vous sont les trois meilleurs réalisateurs que vous avez
travaillé avec oh j'ai eu beaucoup de chance j'ai travaillé avec beaucoup de gens formidables j'ai travaillé avec un petit partenaire Woody Allen en mouvement j'ai travaillé avec Paul mccarskin Robert Alderman et euh Phillip Kaufman et Lawrence kazdan et beaucoup de super
les réalisateurs Philippe a dit que Bon a réalisé Mr Frost et il était merveilleux Je vais vous dire que j'ai passé autant de temps à faire Mr Frost que j'en ai eu sur n'importe quel film quel est votre meilleur film de tous les temps J'aime le plus les dernières choses qui
J'ai fait j'ai un sentiment particulièrement bon à propos de Mr Frost pire je n'ai jamais fait un film que je regarde maintenant et je suis vraiment c'est vrai tourmenté à propos de j'aurais aimé ne pas l'avoir fait je sais que vous
'ai euh que tu vas que tu as été en thérapie un
t euh parfois est-ce que cela aide en tant qu'acteur du tout agir est une étrange combinaison de mentir et de dire la vérité c'est vraiment mentir parce que la circonstance qui vous savez ce que vous dites vous êtes vous faites ce que vous dites vous
sont et et les circonstances sont inventées, c'est un mensonge mais pour rendre cela crédible pour que ce soit comme si c'était la vraie vie, vous devez être véridique d'une autre manière, vous devez en quelque sorte être vous-même d'une certaine manière, même si cela peut être un saut
d'imagination, vous devez être vous-même, donc une thérapie ou quelque chose de thérapeutique qui vous éduque sur vous-même et vous permet de vous connaître et d'être capable de dire la vérité en fait et de vous rendre plus véridique plus authentique moins faux d'une certaine manière euh plus en contact
avec les choses qui signifient quelque chose pour vous et plus en contact avec vos sentiments, le meilleur acteur que vous êtes avez-vous admiré quelqu'un quand vous étiez enfant oh c'est euh la première chose qui me vient à l'esprit est que j'avais un plus vieux
b
rother
nommé Rick qui avait quatre ans de plus que
moi et euh en fait malheureusement quand il avait
23 ans il est mort quand j'avais 19 ans tu sais mais
euh c'était moi je l'ai admiré et la façon dont
il était tu sais je veux dire il a commencé à partir
sortir avec des filles tu sais quand
j'étais encore un peu trop jeune pour et je l'ai vraiment
admiré et euh qu'est-ce que tu
te dis tous les matins quand tu
me vois dans le miroir
je chante tu sais ce matin je pense juste
à ça  matin j'ai chanté j'ai chanté Un
medley de chansons
mentalement de chansons
c'est la vie était l'une des chansons
et et hé regarde moi sur lesquelles